chocolate yeah sure if we went upon five
pounds you're cute but where am I gonna
put you what the heck is this thing
I'm Joanna Stern and I sort of hate
valentines day it's not that I hate love
I love love I just don't think the key
to a relationship can be found in aisle
two I'm not convinced the answer can be
found in your phone either but a number
of apps are hoping to strengthen your
communication with your partner with a
social network for two yeah I thought it
was a stupid idea at first too so we
have Facebook and text messaging for
that but you can think of this as a
private digital getaway just for you
guys all five of these apps offer mostly
the same thing they let you message each
other privately with photos make to-do
lists and share calendars the only way
they really differ from one another is
by offering some sort of cute or
incredibly super corny feature it
depends on how you look at it which app
have I fallen in love with if any
this one's called avocado I like it the
app puts messaging front and center and
adding a to-do list or a calendar item
is easy it's also one of the only
services that offers a web app so you
can message when you're at the computer
I don't like that you have to pay twenty
dollars a year to access to send video
clips or create more than five lists
avocados special corny trick can
actually take the phone and press it to
your heart to send a hug and then you
can tap on your lover's face to send
some kisses still despite all this
corniness it's a really good option
between has a lot of the same features
as avocado I like that you can
personalize the homescreen with a photo
and that you can send voice messages I
love you more than my macbook air but
the chat isn't the first thing that pops
up and there isn't a shared to-do list
feature between a special Corney trip
you can change the background of the
chat to pink and red
twixt has the nicest calendar feature
not only can you share appointments but
with the top of the date you can see all
your past messages and photos from that
day you can password protect it just
like the other ones but it's easier here
to figure out unfortunately
there's no web access special corny
trick included freezing out your lover
when things get too hot you can hit the
freeze button and put a thin layer of
ice on your partner's screen they then
have to break the ice to get to the
message speaking of ice there's another
app called the ice break which aims to
bring couples closer by answering
questions together I really like the
idea but I can't recommend this poorly
designed $2.00 app I actually have
serious privacy concerns with ice
breaker the company says your answers
aren't shared with your name anywhere
but they can appear anonymously to other
users couple has been my favorite it has
the nicest interface and automatically
defaults to the messaging tab from there
you can sketch together send voice notes
and even share your location there's
also a snapchat light feature that will
self-destruct your photos after a few
seconds and with a web app and password
protection there isn't much to dislike
about couple special corny trick time
all dreams come true when you thumb kiss
I prefer a thumb more naturally but here
you can touch fingers digitally okay I
take it back
maybe all the answers can be found in
aisle two and in an app you know I
really even expect to find much use out
of these apps especially when me and my
significant other are to use text
messaging Facebook Google Calendar and a
whole lot of other apps but actually how
to change of heart especially with the
couple app which has a really nice
interface lots of features and web
access I'm still not gonna buy any of
this though